[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here today i'm going to
explain an indonesian comedy drama film
called too handsome to handle
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the moss family has been good-looking
for several generations they are admired
by many because of their beauty which in
turn makes them a lot of money the
eldest son okus is an internet
influencer he has millions of followers
because of his looks and is also
considered a love guru who helps men
impress their crushes the father pakar
used to be a heartbreaker who dated more
than 1200 girls before meeting their
mother meanwhile the mother can also be
considered handsome because of her
masculine features and an obvious
mustache lastly the protagonist coulin
is the youngest son and the most
attractive of them all the family has
gotten used to their life as people with
good looks except for coolan who
struggles to live normally because of
his handsomeness he often wishes he was
only mildly attractive that way he could
go out without being chased by a crowd
of women every time girls go crazy pass
out pull their hair and often get
nosebleeds on getting a look at his
attractive face poor poor coolan as a
result he has never had a genuine
interaction with a girl he avoids going
out in public as much as possible and
has been homeschooled until now coolan
has no friends he can talk to other than
his pet fish he often plays cards with
it and talks to it out loud his family
watches him through a camera in worry
they want him to have a normal teenage
life and try their best to help him okus
frequently shows him pictures of girls
trying to hook him up with someone
however coolan says that his type in
girls is someone who doesn't like him he
wants to be seen for his personality and
interest not his face perhaps coolant
wants to date his fish when nothing
works out to motivate coolant to go out
the family takes it a step further they
plan to fake financial problems and
guilt him into going to school one night
when coolan wakes up to drink water his
parents pretend to be worried about
their finances they dramatically declare
that they will only eat scrambled eggs
for breakfast until they earn enough
money for coolin's homeschooling he
feels awful to be causing his parents so
much trouble the next morning he
declares that he will be going to school
for the upcoming semester the family is
overjoyed until he mentions that he will
only go to an all-boys school although
they would have preferred him to be able
to talk to girls they are happy to take
one step at a time a few days later is
kulin's first day at an actual school
okus drops him off on his bike but
coolan doesn't take his helmet off he
plans to wear it the entire day to hide
the fact that he is handsome however the
plan backfires when the helmet grabs
more attention than he intended it to
coolan quietly sits down in the last
seat but is called out by the class
bully cd and his minions when the
teacher enters the classroom she too is
surprised to see a guy with a helmet she
urges him to take it off right that
instant although reluctant coulin has no
way but to oblige he slowly takes the
helmet off in a dramatic way revealing
his face that plan backfired hard in the
following scene the teacher is being
loaded into an ambulance it turns out
that she started to nosebleed and
hyperventilate because of coolin's
beauty the other kids complained to the
principal that the new student is too
handsome to handle coolan runs through
the hallway to go back home but is
tripped by one of the bullies they bring
him to the school's storeroom and
introduce themselves like they are power
rangers they are called the tiga talk a
group of three bullies led by sidi the
principal's son after the over-the-top
introduction they reveal that they need
coolant's help to ask a girl out for
prom the group has been in the senior
year of school for the past three years
they refuse to graduate until sidi goes
to the prom with the most beautiful girl
of the bbm school amanda however she
only accepts requests from handsome men
so the group wants coolin to deliver the
promposal they assign an innocent guy
kibo to help coolan and lead the way
kibo has also been a victim of their
pranks in the past and is obliged to do
whatever the bullies say afterward
coolan goes to the principal's office
with kibo to make an official complaint
about bullying in school kibo knows what
the outcome will be but he still
accompanies coolan the principal is
troubled by his son refusing to graduate
since kulin's beauty gives him a chance
to take amanda to the prom the principal
wants them to do whatever the bullies
say
that evening coolant and kibo decide to
complete the task the next day and get
rid of the responsibility kibo is the
first person who has shown kindness to
coulon unrelated to his beauty although
the day didn't go as planned he is happy
to have gained a friend the next morning
they go to the bbm school where the
girls smell the presence of the boys
they are strict about not allowing ugly
boys to enter the school premises hence
when they notice kulin wearing a helmet
the entire school asks him to take it
off in a climactic scene coolant takes
the helmet off and mayhem ensues among
the girls poor poor coolan only a few
hours later the news makes it to the
television clips of girls crying
bleeding through their noses getting
possessed and jumping around are being
shared all around social media coolant
starts being known as the too handsome
to handle guy the hottest student of the
bbm school and model named amanda also
hears the news and is instantly smitten
with coolan he is the first guy who
matches in beauty and status with her
she immediately makes it her mission to
impress him when the news becomes huge a
crowd of girls gathers in front of the
mass residents the family starts
charging them money for a house tour
coulon who is hiding in the streets sees
his family on the news he feels betrayed
and used by his own people when they
call him he refuses to come home and
feels even sadder when his pet fish is
mishandled and killed by the tourists he
is now on the roof of a building hiding
from the maniacs chasing him in the
streets suddenly a girl appears behind
him and inquires if he is going to jump
off the roof coolan looks at her in
shock because she doesn't bleed from her
nose or pass out upon seeing him the
girl refuses to talk and simply walks
away coolan is so nervous that he can
hardly speak the encounter makes his day
a lot better a while later he calls kibo
who picks him up and invites him to his
home he and his grandmother welcome
coolan to stay for as long as he wants
on walking into kibo's room he sees two
rare collectible playing cards and is
amazed by them they realize that they
share several common interests and
playing card collection is one of them
the following day they visit the
all-girls school to look for the girl
from yesterday while they are at it they
also meet amanda and give her the files
of the promposal sent by sidi amanda
pretends to be unimpressed by coolin's
beauty but after he leaves her nose
bleeds profusely kulin sees his crush on
the stairs but the other girls
surrounding him do not allow him to meet
her for the next few days kibo and kulin
do everything together and become best
friends one afternoon kibo takes coolin
to play futsal where he frequently goes
to meet his crush riri after the match
coolin notices the girl from the roof
working at a shop nearby he cannot help
but stare at her just then kibo arrives
and introduces riri to him coolan
discovers that she is also kibo's crush
who he was talking about earlier the two
seem to be pretty close which makes
coolan jealous he can hardly fall asleep
that night because the feeling is new
and confusing to him then he remembers
okus is a love guru and fixes a meeting
with him when they meet the following
morning okus breaks down crying tears of
happiness he has been waiting for this
day to give his brother advice on girls
coolan has forgiven his family for
selling him out to his fans because if
that had not happened he would never
have met riri the brothers then go
shopping for groceries while okus lists
out the points of things coolin should
do to impress his crush as coolan
follows okus's suggestions he registers
he is far from knowing riri like kibo
knows her but he still doesn't want to
give up on his first love one afternoon
amanda comes to the boys school and
hands cool in an invitation for her
birthday alongside it she also gives him
a phone as a gift later that day kibo
coolan and riri go to karaoke eventually
riri and kulin get to sing together
while coolan is excited to duet with her
riri only focuses on kibo he soon
registers that she also likes kibo back
the revelation makes his heart crumble
in jealousy so when kibo is not around
he bluntly asks her if she has a crush
on him initially riri denies it but when
coolin lies about kibo being in love
with amanda her face drops her
expression is enough to confirm his
suspicions after returning home cooling
calls amanda and asks her for a favor
she happily agrees to do anything he
says the next day several people gather
at the venue to celebrate her birthday
when coolin and kibo arrive amanda
welcomes them strangely enough she seems
to be more interested in kibo than in
kulin she even pulls him aside to talk
to him in private at the same time riri
arrives at the party and sees amanda
kissing kibo heartbroken she runs
outside taking advantage of her
vulnerability coulin confesses his
feelings for her riri thanks him but
claims that she never saw him as someone
more than a friend even after conspiring
against his only best friend coolan gets
nothing in return the group of bullies
also see amanda kissing kibo and are
enraged with jealousy and anger they
beat kibo up for it while kuhlin watches
from nearby too scared to interfere
later he brings kibo home and dresses
his wounds alongside his grandmother
only after seeing him moan in pain does
kulin realize that he has made a huge
mistake
the next day kibo gives him a legendary
card from his card collection that
coolan had been wanting for a long time
guilt-ridden coolan confesses to
everything wrong he has done until now
kibo is shocked and hurt by the betrayal
he claims that he would have left riri
if he knew coolant liked her too the
words do nothing but hurt coolan even
more at last kibo orders him to get out
of the house immediately knowing that he
is in the wrong coulon simply leaves he
finally returns home after a month his
family is overjoyed but the same cannot
be said for coolin he locks himself in
his room and doesn't talk to anyone but
most of all he misses his best friend
the two bump into each other at times
but never share anything more than a
glance at home coolan's mother is
worried about his well-being she
approaches him one night and gives him
his pet fish that never died she also
tells him that he can go back to being
homeschooled if that is what he prefers
the family only wants his happiness and
is ready to do anything for it coolan
touched by her words realizes that he
has people in his life who are rooting
for his success this motivates him to
make things right between him and kibo
the next morning he runs to riri and
tells her everything following that he
goes to kibo and tries to apologize
although kibo dismisses him at first
when asked about riri he starts to
describe how much he loves her coolin
shows him that riri was listening to him
on the phone the entire time that way he
mends their relationship and goes back
to being both of their friend a few days
later they all go to prom together
kibo's date is riri while coolan's date
is amanda whatever happened to that
bully cd
who cares as expected coolan and amanda
win the title of prom king and queen
coolin hears a girl comment that he is
only mildly handsome and is instantly
drawn to her indicating the start of a
new relationship subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching